yeah welcome again to new game against
my way from Norway and then again black
I always have black against the sky
let's see I think he's playing the
Scotch am ok let's play again my special
team this is this night f5 I actually
had this in a tournament game once and
played d6 time was interesting it's not
the necessary to do that yeah but it's
an interesting way to play getting a
very quick development my g4 on f2 and
dumb ok Queen to d2 antenna Queen age 6
so what now how do you protect our two
now
what does why plano you came
yeah let's just just take it for the
moment and wow this looks like really
really bad and look how to how to punish
it Bishop takes Queen takes is probably
not the way to go hmm yeah he's not
threatening much really Quinn g5 me
hmm
yeah I don't really know should I remove
the queen but a mess hmm
or retreat this this Bishop and he's got
age 3 coming
is it some idea play play this move
attending night g6 so on Queen g5 I can
take on g3 what is he moving now 96
each three i can take g g3 night g 6 s
my mouth red queen g5 then Bishop g3 and
wins material I don't know what is side
doing against that it's not like he's
got many big moves that I think a simple
development move doesn't who doesn't
really help ya know this what are you
put are you doing Knight f3 or something
or where's the Queen even going I to f3
you can go to a three but the Queen and
not it's not great-looking or anything
night yeah this is the repetition funky
but wait wait wait wait let's do this
what is he doing now Queen afro and then
Bishop e3 yeah there should be three
since winning the Queen almost doesn't
have asked way I am
yeah don't tell me the safes mmm
how sick is this
unbelievable
ah chess is a sick game sometimes yeah
it's equal material now can you believe
that not not winning this outright is
really heartbreaking this is complete
nonsense yeah okay if you look at it
with a computer to computer afterwards
you always feel like a complete idiot my
black is still better i mean this only
shows that it must have been completely
lost before but still not winning this
out right this is really a shame okay so
with a for it so it's quite quite good
the good thing is sort of this is
excellent night on on on e5 trying to
improve him
I can actually take you for I know that
no but I look at it and this is soon
it's good
hmm don't I have a good discovered check
here and maybe this first cutting
cutting off the the rank didn't really
help okay
hmm check
Jeff
want to activate the rupee I don't care
so much about the apron
Lucas sound quite nice on the
third-ranked attacking h3 and c3
time warning check check check
check
check I made on edge for ya check me
yeah okay yeah spending too much time
here yeah having lost that is quite
humiliating I mean even this what yeah
he wrote was lucky and this is a true in
that but didn't need to tell me I know
okay thats just look quickly how I could
have one insolently in the opening just
ridiculous yeah this is actually the
right move night d three what okay
headlight III is not so easy to see okay
yeah this is very nice winning the Queen
and he doesn't have a move and this um
ok this is really saving him for the
moment it still leaves a white with the
terrible position but it's not a mate
and I'm downer down on the clock but not
so much d 5 wins our God what the crap
game wha haha let's play another one
thanks for watching